大妈，
但凡是能够保证两三年的时间，
保证能租上房子，
能吃饱饭，
咱就能干这个事儿，
就叫生扎根，
就像一个竹子一样，
我要两三年的时间，
我可能很贫穷，
但是我生扎根在这个领域，
我两三年我就能干成这个领域的专家。
我现在是一为学习律师，
下周就会拿到直播点，
我想问的是关于职业规划方面的问题，
好，
你说主要是包括专业能力跟安然拓展，
还有团队选择，
包括我即将面临的是职业之后，
在有选择的情况下，
我是选授权律师还是独立律师，
我是24岁，
法学二本本科，
在成都工作，
没有资源，
没有人脉，
因为我是外省的，
我所在的律所是一个传统所，
20人左右，
所在的团队是5年，
我的师傅他职业是18年，
年收入在100多，
除我之外，
团队成员均为独立律师，
但是师傅的话会给他们案子，
大师姐是在团队10年，
团队内收入是10多个，
二师姐是8年，
然后团队内收入是20个左右，
师兄是4年，
师兄主要是跟法律咨询公司合作，
然后师傅给他很少，
师傅自己也会消化一部分案件。
目前团队内案件量并不饱和，
存在内部竞争，
案件质量的话。
目前我觉得我不话多说，
判断等于是有案子纠错，
但相对来讲并不存在低价竞争，
我们成员的办案能力较强。
第一个问题是关于职业后选择授权律师还是独立律师的问题。
之前我们团队授薪律师的模式是3000底薪加提成，
提成大概是每个案件是20%，
没有社保，
我在跟师傅提出要求可以降低底薪，
希望他给我缴纳社保，
但是师傅拒绝了，
提出了说可以让我做独立意识，
我接受了，
但他后期好像又反悔了，
虽然没有明确的表达出来想要我做寿星，
但是能够感觉到他还是想让我做寿星。
关于寿星的其实工作量我能够接受，
因为我们工作量并不饱和，
主要是我感觉跟师傅相处下来心理压力比较大，
怎么做，
好像他就是也不太满意，
还有一个问题就是一到下班时间，
比如说我没有工作到下班，
或者半个小时之后，
我会说没有工作的话，
我就先下班了，
然后他就会不开心，
就是必须要要等到他一起下班。
但是我觉得如果说我有工作，
在我有工作的情况下，
我加班我是可以接受的，
但是没有工作的情况下，
让我在那儿呆着等着，
我觉得不是我想要的工作状态。
还有一个就是不太喜欢办公室的氛围，
因为我没点敏感。
可能不容易变胖，
我跟我们团队所在的师兄沟通过之后，
他的建议就是就先让我做半年寿星，
然后做一个渗透。
直接独立的话，
可能认为师傅不太友好，
我之前也并没有想做，
就是说直接独立，
想的是先做一两年的授精，
做一个过渡。
另外一个方面也是毕竟是师傅带出来的，
也会也回报，
但是师傅主动提出来做独立，
我想了一想也可以接受，
而且我觉得可能独立也是我想要的生活状态，
独立之后可能面临的就是爱人的问题，
但我想的是可以多跟同事合作，
或者是说自己做一下自媒体，
之前有做过两个月的媒体，
通过直播，
但是效果可能不太理想，
因为平时上一天班下来，
晚上在熬夜和直播的话，
可能自己精力不太够，
爸妈是干啥的，
做一些小生意，
但是他们没办法提供一些不允许，
就是保证，
比如说房租800块钱，
1000块钱，
你的那个吃饭生活费能保证这个吗？
可以的是吧，
如果我说我需要的话，
他们是不给的。
好姑娘，
我给你聊一下我自己的一路成长的过程啊，
供你参考。
我从我进入律师行业的第一天起，
我就没有想过要一辈子给人当助理或者怎么怎么样，
我从我的第一天起，
我跟着我的师傅，
我就没有想过要跟着他一辈子要干嘛干嘛的啊，
从第一天我的目标就非明。
准确，
我一定是要成为一个独立律师的，
因为只有成为独立律师了，
我做这份工作，
他的自由的价值才能得到体现。
我为啥选择做律师，
为啥没有考法官、
检察官，
没有考公检法，
我想要的就是这一份自由，
想要就是这份自己做主的这个底气。
所以呢，
我感觉就这事儿的话，
如果说父母能给到支撑，
租房子吃饭不成问题的话，
就做独立律师，
为什么？
因为你做了独立律师了之后，
你才知道我从今天开始已经没有人在护着我了，
没有人在怎么怎么样了啊，
就必须要靠我自己去刨食儿了，
必须要靠我自己在这个竞争残酷的行业里面去摸爬滚打了，
你那个时候才有可能激发出来你那种斗志，
像一个死士一样的斗志，
我自己是更倾向于这个，
因为我想的是反正总会面临这种状态，
倒不如现在彼此一发，
对，
这是一方面，
就是我问你了，
就是原生家庭，
但凡能给你提供租房子吃的饱饭，
我感觉就做一个独立的律师，
做一个独立的律师，
接下来就是你要选择一个职业方向，
要选择一个专业方向，
像那种说啊，
什么案子都干的这种情况的话，
我认为啊，
其实不太适合我们现在这些年轻的律师这个路子了，
我们就是要选一个职业方向，
我举个例子吧，
说我们律所有一个选择了劳动法这个职业方向的，
他本来刚开始在我们律所的时候就是一个横面性格，
非常。
能面面到什么程度呢？
就是谁都能安排他干点事儿，
谁都能安排他这帮个忙那帮个忙那样的性格，
但他一旦自己选择了劳动法这个专业，
他每天都会在他的朋友圈去分享案例，
这个分享案例一定是一压拨吃，
什么叫一压拨吃呢？
就是说这个文字对案例我给扒下来了，
我对案例的分析我用文字的方式给他输出了，
同时的话，
我给他拍成作品，
拍成视频，
就是一个问题提出来，
接下来就是我应对这个问题的，
就比如说没有通知你就给你，
呃，
解雇啊，
你应该第一时间干什么啊，
录音啊，
找什么样的证据啊，
这些都可以作为小小的专题，
它就是这种一压多吃的方法，
一方面是文字性的，
另一方面是视频类的，
再有一个，
他可以总结成书籍，
可以出书的，
从现在开始，
如果说你要选择一个专业领域的话，
就这个专业领域所有高院的判决，
高院出的一些案例库，
最高院出的一些案例指导，
全都得研究，
如果你选择这个领域的话，
每天没事儿我就研究案例，
研究案例，
研究一下这个新出的司法解释，
研究不同高院不同的指导意见、
倾向性意见，
你就干这个，
你只要有两年的时间，
你就能成为这个领域的专家，
你一旦成为这个领域的专家了之后，
很多时候你在跟客户谈判的时候非常有底气，
顶多菲姐如果能说我们专攻一个方向的话，
可能易就是温保的问题，
我不跟你说了吗？
你爸妈但凡是能够保证两。
3年的时间保证能租上房子，
能吃饱饭，
咱就能干这个事儿，
就叫生扎根，
就像一个竹子一样，
我要两三年的时间，
我可能很贫穷，
但是我生扎根在这个领域，
我两三年我就能干成这个领域的专家，
然后自媒体这个事儿坚持干，
就像我跟你说的，
一压多吃，
就一个问题出来了之后，
我不光是有文字稿的，
我还有视频内容的，
而且各平台都发，
你不招哪块云彩钓鱼，
就是各个平台都发，
你不道哪块云彩就钓鱼了，
哪怕我在线上，
我收一些那个线上咨询的，
我基本上也能养活自己。
嗯，
这就是如果我选择独立的话，
师傅会给我提供这个方案，
就是在独立跟上网站里面选，
后续的话该如何跟他谈，
你自己心里要明确的知道，
如果你有这股劲儿，
啃老啃个两三年，
但是我总有一天我自己能独立在这个社会上去竞争，
去刨食儿，
那你就要有底气，
别那个啥你左右亿摆的，
人家一说怎么怎么的，
你就软了，
就塌了，
因为这意思啊，
好的好的专，
专业选择方面，
如果说我真的是选择深耕一个的话，
就是很难判断，
我觉得这是我们当职业律师都会面临的一个问题，
这个事情是这样的，
你可以去看一下行业报告，
行业里面应该有这方面的报告去分析，
以前我看到的时候，
比如说有些看上去非常高大上的业务，
对不对？
举个例子吧，
上市IPO，
这是一个非常高大上的业务，
但其实这块业务它一年就这么。
IPO,
而且还未必能成功，
所以他蛋糕只有那么大，
我当时就分析过，
就是婚姻方面，
他确实盘子越来越大，
因为这个离婚率在这摆着，
尤其是北上广深这方面，
他一离婚的话，
涉及的房产就是几百万啊，
你随便收点2%，
3%的这样一个律师费的话，
就是八万十万，
我当时分析的就是这个，
你可能现在你再自己去看一下，
类似于这些行业报告的分析，
就是说律师这个行业整体的盘子有多大，
律师这个行业整体的产值有多大，
那么不同的业务在这个产值里面占的比重有多大，
看大的方向，
然后选一个好的啊。
龙飞姐，
你认为还有必要再去读的研究生吗？
因为目前我是二本，
我们团队内都是我的学生，
师姐，
就是同一个学校毕业的，
坦率的说啊，
如果你在专业这个领域走顺了，
路走通了，
能挣到钱了，
钱越挣越多了，
其实读研究生大可不必，
但如果说你专业领域你没走顺，
你没有钱越挣越多，
那你可能比如说换个方向，
你比如说举个例子啊，
你干婚姻这一块子，
你干了三年没起色，
起不来，
你可能想换个方向，
比如说干劳动这方面，
那你说你读个研究生，
读个这方面的研究生，
有没有帮助，
有一定的帮助，
就这意思啊的，
明白明白好的，
谢谢学姐，
好，
嗯，
拜拜啊，
就是好多姐妹都知道啊，
就是我呢，
律师专业能力呢，
一般，
我这里的一般你。
跟谁比？
我跟那种干了20年，
干了30年的哥哥姐姐比，
那我肯定是一般，
但是我跟同龄人比的话，
我从来不处，
为什么？
就是因为我这个学习的劲头永远在再鼓励一下刚才那个姐妹啊，
就是你们当地一定有律协，
律协一定会组织一些学习的课程，
我们当时的北京的律协组织法官来讲课，
检察官来讲课，
公证人员来讲课，
大学的老师来讲课，
教授来讲课，
就各种呃，
律师前辈来讲课，
我相当于课课不落，
就周末我不是在听课，
就是在听课的路上，
那会儿确实方向不明，
所以什么课都听，
什么形式啊，
证据分析我去听，
公证实务我去听讲，
什么房产纠纷啊，
二手房买卖我去听讲，
什么继承纠纷啊，
这个我都去听，
因为我讲的都是我来时的路，
都是干货，
包括我刚刚讲的，
你要看整个行业的大盘子，
你要看整个行业的产值，
这个行业分几块豆腐，
这几块豆腐的话分别产值怎么样，
你才对你将来选择方向，
选择专业有一定的大的指导的作用。
但平时生活中，
因为我们做律师的人很少有商业头脑，
很少有人去用商业的视角来看律师的业务，
很少你知道吧，
都是埋头干事儿，
都是各种什么介绍案员，
就这那的啊，
记得点赞关注哦。